hello everyone
good i guess you're starting to
get a little strong me too and
that's why i matched the best
thing the best announcements for the
end of this presentation
good just kidding i'm a man and i
am going to present the roadmap to you
today but before starting
I would like to know who in the room is
already using I am following in their
company
very well I see a lot of taking myself away
I like it a lot among those who do
n't have the v l  lover who is considering a
safe passage I am in the next few
months or over the next year to come
there are two three so that is
what is most important
for our clients
is that this Jesuit has passed  it's not
for digital transformation
it's not just technology
it's above all Jesuit culture
and the most natural way to
work together
is the solution of
smart applications that have been created to
bring your teams closer  so that  'they
are more agile and more efficient and
so that it can win against the
competition
for those who do not know Jesuit
all these applications are grouped
around four axes the first
is creation so you don't break
the initiative with  appropriate tools
for your business google documents
such as google docs google [ __ ] google
slide allow you
real-time collaboration google forms
gives you the possibility to create
questionnaires in a few clicks and
also to have the answers
instantly
you also have  google has for
the group and the various
important relevant training for your
projects and that without the need for
specific development skills
we also have google which for
task management and note taking that can be
shared with your collaborators and
we also have a  recent edition job board
it is a new product in the
radar range which allows your teams
to erase the distances
if you have several sites which want to
collaborate together and the last of
this brick the seat mesquer which is a
product to give the possibility to your
collaborators decree and easily
business applications so the second
pillar is communication
stay in touch with your
collaborators or whether it is with gmail
which is our calendar messaging tool
to find the best availability
of different people and also
manage appointments
google+ for a
corporate social network google limit for
videoconferencing and google  and google chat
sorry for a cat you named wise instant rice feature-
rich
sharing and also search
the third axis is the axis here you
have the option to host your
documents in the cloud on google drive
so you can host  google documents
that you create directly google
drive but you can also
add documents from others  es forms has conceded
m
fake microsoft office images
videos and you can use google
cloud cents for easy search
which allows you to access the best
information with a single
search engine on the entire
jesuit platform so the last axis of account and
control etc in two of the most
important for our customers since
knowing how to manage users and
their device
is very important and this can be
done with the administration console
and also knowing how to access archives and be
able to do legal research
with  google god can be quite
important in this presentation we have
the group and the different novelties
by theme
so we have three of them the transformation of
work with new ways of
working
exploitation of data and intelligence
of tools to help you to assist you
in  decision-making and
of course safety
each of these themes is linked to
one of the pro  problems that we have already
encountered with our customers and that we are
trying to solve with Jesuit
traditional productivity tools
have improved in recent years
but they were not necessarily designed
for collaborative teamwork
many innovative companies have
understood this and have made the choice to
switch to Jesuit Jesuit
radically changes the way people
work and interact
it brings more agility and more
collaboration more efficiency and
most importantly more commitment for
your employees
the teams work  better this Jesuit
and our goal is to help
companies find new
ways of working simpler more
intuitive and by connecting all
people and all their ideas without
any borders
a way to help transformation to
a way to help  transforming the
way people work and
breaking down content silos silos
are a major challenge  we hear it
all the time from our
potential customers international companies
remote workers
different departments and
separate projects create silos across an
organization information stays pg in those silos
making it difficult to work
collaboratively  very often too
even people prefer to start from scratch rather
than rely on things
already existing projects
among the most well-known challenges that we
can see in the workplace
today we can mention the reduction
in the number of e  -mails korea either for
example in a company but also
the management of outings between and
collaborators and also the excesses that they
may have to document so I am
constantly working to
connect people within organizations
that is why we have  already launched
different google cloud products serge
quick access and tim drive and we
have improved its products with new
new features such
as google
renzaho chat, for example, we have also added
the integration of google cloud cents on
the different sites which will allow you
to search on sites
with the power of the google cloud cents engine,
so we have also added
recognition of the  'handwriting
on a board as well as the discovery
and exploration of drive documents for
sharing on a job board is also
another fairly important feature
it is the recording of hang
out videos and their saving on the drive
we have completely ironed a
gadget with a team-centric
approach to facilitate
business conversations
we have introduced the concept of rooms
to better manage discussions especially
around a project the platform will
also be open for the integration of
boot chats and
third-party applications  and better management
of document sharing will be provided
when, for example,  n we will add a
document from a the room
it will automatically be shared with
the people taking part in this
conversation there the search engine
will of course also be integrated to go dalo
en ga au chad which will allow your
collaborators to do research
in  the history of the conversation in
a very simple and very intuitive way without
going to look in historical pages and
pages a swarm of
remembering the discussion they had on
such a date to find such a
Jesuit document was born from a desire to
accelerating collaboration in companies
is to move from a personal culture
to a culture of sharing
it is very difficult with traditional tools
to promote
collaboration between businesses with
is inherent and even enter
people from different departments or
working on  of the different projects
the mobile employees have to communicate
with the colleague or whether it is in front of
their desk or to elect the u  n travel
to customers so even
remotely employees must be able to share
their ideas and communicate easily
despite anywhere in the world
any language and culture
everyone in a company must
be able to be recognized and communicate
with  using a digital identity to
address pollutants we have already
announced and launched certain products such as
a google cloud set I
mentioned earlier to warn against this myth
jobboards sight and google+ and we
continue to strengthen our tools on
key points  in particular we will
increase the capacity up to 50
people
fifty participants as well as the
diversification of telephone points
on another myth guy
we will add the possibility of being able to
present from a laptop on
board meetings and we will also have the
possibility  to have a global view of
google+ posts and a better
suggestion and search of communities
for the differences on the go  group of
employees as well as the possibility
of sending
emails to members in a driven team
although productivity tools have
greatly evolved in companies
they have been overtaken by emerging technology
which has changed the way
all people work today  Today
as a Jesuit platform brings a
destructive vision that breaks
work habits that haven't
changed for years and
years by improving productivity
and changing besson 2.1 processes
eliminating redundant tasks  and
low added value and 3 by
reducing the part of that of haiti which
pushes employees to use
solutions not accepted by not authorized
by companies in order to solve
problems for which they cannot find the
appropriate tools
google apps mesquer a  was pinched in this
direction to easily automate
redundant tasks by creating
workflows
but for the trades and also to
reduce  re the number of recurring actions
and mines and the head of Haiti we are
going to set up the integration
of one of the third-party tools such as for
example drive notifications in
that is the addition of a framework
for the creation of  gmail add-on including
four best
is a new
so-called
local application development tool for Jesuits that
allows different companies to
very quickly design and deploy
custom applications to
meet their specific needs
without development skills
particular you can transform your
ideas into an application in a few days
instead of a few months a short
time ago
among the most common examples
carried out with aq mesquer we find the
management of the lists
the dashboards the automation
of the processes creation of the reports
as well as utilities and
alerts nowadays there is more and more
data and in emails it is
quite difficult  usable because it
is data in text format
most of the time we just need to
answer an email
but very often we would like
external rich information such as for example
accessing a profile of a person
present in the  list of emails or
transform the content of emails into a
task to be processed later
these examples and many others may
now be processed with
third-party applications that will enrich the
functionality of gmail
the second category of
functionality that we have  seen
just now was at cid reached 1.7 and
intelligence companies do not gain
a well without competitive advantage
if they are able to bring together the
different sources of data and
above all to make them available
then employees and find the correlation
the colors  correlations that
are not obvious
so we want to help
companies make smarter informed decisions
and everything  it in real time
with Jesuit each employee and not
only on with a haiti background
where 1 with ethics is pushed to use
this data in their everyday work
to better slay them we
are convinced that all trades
must become datacenter with  the
time companies have collected so
much data that the process
of organizing and exploiting this
data has become very very difficult
1 and Jesuit's focus is to
facilitate access to data to put it at
the heart of the process  decision-making
that's why google cloud certainly
will also be able to search
in external sources agi suite
you could therefore connect your
databases your sources
your archives on google cloud touch and
with a single tool you will find
what you
imagine so  the search engine power
that you know and
use all I imagine connecting to
the dataset of an enter
taking gmail and drive via doc
[ __ ] agenda slide and more google
cloud serge answers your questions and
accompanies you all day with
relevant suggestions and that in a proactive way
so you have suggestions
according to your agenda according to
historical vote of your documents on
which you were
working which are
proactively pushed to you so that you do not have to
go and find
here is a small example which illustrates a
search for a person with google
cloud of course we find so we could
see more  contact details
also the last emails and documents
exchanged as
well as the history of appointments
with this person there quite
impressive
the administrators need to
monitor the uses of Jesuits in
companies in order to be able to identify
potential security risks
also measure the  adoption
of ti differences and level of collaboration as
well as having access to  other
key indicators for teams and
teams we have also improved our
tools to take an exploitation of the
logs on big willie and also
provide new metrics on the use
of dream and google+ and job board so
a major phishing attack can
be a disaster for a business
with smart tools for your
security teams
you can increase their efficiency by
allowing them to
focus their efforts on the challenges that
matter most
google is a born in the cloud company
run the cloud and many
customers  have trusted us they have
built their own business on the
google cloud 9,700
security engineers bring this expertise to our
google cloud offers our
global infrastructure and our DNA of
permanent innovation on Jesuit offer you a
highly secure environment
reliable and
historically compliant  companies have
used tools for  farol from vpn under
the corporate dpc to secure access
to data
this also allows administrators
to have greater transparency and
governance of users but
today the work habits
when I told you earlier
have changed  and employees
expect technology to adapt to
their needs and not the reverse
our objective at google and
to increase user freedom
without compromising data security
for this we have implemented
security systems  advanced at the level
of our infrastructures but also
with tools centered on the users
and weisz tells them could well
maximize the risk
another axis of major improvement
and a mini to the Jesuit administrators
more control and better
visibility allowing them to
focus on strategic projects
we will increase the catalog
of applications that comes to integrate with
the platform including 50 new  new
applications by sso and 15 by auto
provisioning we are also adding the
possibility of having new
dashboards and api for the management
of registered projects as well as
the integration of google groups on
google+
the cloud identity allows you to manage
the identity of  people and various
who use cloud services
it also simplifies their
administration by including
management and provisioning workflows and
provisioning and groups of rights
with the other 50 applications that we
will support soon
so you will have access to more  of
800 applications natively connected to
claudine astier one of the major subjects of
this roadmap and of course trust
with new regulations
such as gdp in france
google created jesuit with
security and privacy standards based on industry best
practices but  also with
control tools to help our
customers stay comp  be careful with the
different regulations of the countries where
it operates so
we are going to add
a ditch for sharing and research
on google +
outside the domain especially and with api
for research and export on google
volts so I come to you  present
some of the most
strategic features of the roadmap there are
of course many others coming
soon to get to
know the complete list of these new
features
don't hesitate for existing customers
and even for potential customers of
yours  put in touch with your point
of contact at google for a
personalized demonstration
therefore in conclusion the
permanent evolution of the business world
being in perpetual growth
it is essential for everyone
to go faster to go further than
the  competition by engaging
company employees at the Jesuit is your
greatest asset and we
invest continuously  naked in its tools to
help you achieve your
goals faster with these
I invite guillaume from central ring on
stage to share their great
solution for telephony followed by a
customer testimonial
hello to all so I'm going to try  to
introduce you briefly ring central
ring central we are a
unified communications solution hosted in
the cloud
we are number one in terms
of market share which means
approximately 425 thousand companies that are customers of
our solutions
I am talking about companies and not  not
just users around the
world
we hope to reach in
revenue about 4,175 million
dollars this year
it's quite significant growth
especially over the last two years
I mentioned the number of
business customers we had more  of three
hundred thousand business customers who
have joined us over the last two
years, so the increase is strong  e
and we are also a
public company whose valuation
now exceeds 3 billion
dollars which gives a certain basis
and security credibility at the level of
our customers we also have the
recognition of spear of the industry
we are referenced as a leader  in
the magic kingdom of garner for the
last three years
we have also been company of the year
for two years at frost sullivan and
we are also the leaders at ea hs
so it is generally quite reassuring
for companies that do
not necessarily know  the name to see that
we are known on the market
so what is a
unified collaboration solution
it is first of all a solution we will say
traditional telephony which
includes voice fax and the part  messaging
but in addition to that we also bring the
applications that we will also qualify for
these two traditional
conference and web collaboration as well  than
the call center but the main
differentiator is the ability to
integrate so the open platform api part
is the element I would say under
recently why people are
joining and I'll explain a bit
later in the part  integration what
are the applications the
users of these integrations
we also have collaboration this
is also the new way of
working
if you used to send a
lot of emails from
to send the same attachment to 150
people I would say that
collaboration is what allowed me
to stop sending emails
and use a client on which I
invite people to share documents
and no longer to work with
emails  that's how I defined
in addition we have global coverage
so that allows us to provide a
unified centralized solution to our
customers who have an
international presence by everyone
our solution therefore presents them  that we have
I would say two levels of
telephone solutions what we call the global
office it allows depending on the
geographical location you will see so you see
in orange it is the solution which allows
not only to have numbers but
to  have a flat rate offer of
competitive calling missions in this
geographical area
so yes the presence and in the
mainly so
2 in the united states north america europe
australia and asia pacific on top of
that we are able to
allocate numbers in  the part that is
dark blue standing there is a
virtual number with which we do not
necessarily have a
flat rate communication offer but per-
minute pricing and have made
the system evolve I would say every
month every month we  we are looking to
cover new geographical areas
of new countries and we are also trying to
expand on the flat rate part, so
the orange part that we said
to expand, so what is it?  ue it
also means an infrastructure
we often have customers who say
yes to us but being hosted is what I
will have my quality of service
how does it work we already have
we are in compliance with the
regulators so that is to say that the
part  telephony follows local regulations
so we support everything related
to emergency call service which is
not necessarily the case
for all offers, i.e.
it is a primary service that can
replace your incumbent operator
our infrastructure years use it a
data infrastructure with 17
datacenters all over the world and we
also have to ensure the quality of
service agreements with operators
providing internet access
we provide a telephony solution
over ip
so in order to ensure  the quality of service
we have more than 200 years of agreements
with the operators is spé
so whatever your operator your
internet service provider
we are ca  able to provide the same
quality of service as him with his
own off who are our customers we had
my address
practically all vertical sectors
from distribution to technologies
services health education
everyone can thanks to our
ability to  integration benefit from
the central ring offer
not only do we have the capacity to address
everyone from a vertical point,
we can also from a capacity point of view
start with a subscriber up to infinity,
so roughly speaking  there are no limits
we accept everyone the license can
be for one person for one hundred per
hundred thousand all customers can
be addressed by the solution the strength
I would say of our solution
is integration with the  core business, that is
to say that now we are no longer in
a world where we are necessarily looking for a
telephony offer
we are looking for a telephony offer that
integrates with my core business
so we have the so-
called core integrations so the  'heart integration
is the one that we can see in the middle
where we will first retrieve
via google integration in particular the
user database so you
don't have when you select a
central you don't have  you don't have to recreate all
your telephony subscribers
we recover the existing bases
you just have to assign them the
telephone numbers if they were not already
present in your user base
those are the body integrations and
then we have the  business integrations what
is your job what is your
crm base it's strength the ability to be
able when you receive a
phone call to see the rise
of information the rise of files which
means that you immediately know who
you are talking to  you know the history
all the activities that helped
that took place with this person calling you
the
telephone activity the email activity so we are integrated
with all the standard tools that's
what really makes the difference  rce and it's
as we can see afterwards in the
biggest circle it's what makes
us selected by very big names
in the industry
so to also talk a bit about what
is our involvement vis-à-vis  -vis the
google solution as you can
see at each step each
google module we have a level of integration
when we are at the chrome level we at the
part except phone so it is an
extension which is accessible in the
brother  in chrome in the
internet browser we have the ability to
also integrate with the taste of drives where all
the archiving of your history
the recording of communications
can be stored on your google
drive on integration with a guy
august for  being able to launch
a videoconference with a card
also has in the googledocs the possibility
of sending faxes directly from google
docs
obviously in the calendar the gmail
or the integration with the calendar all
your appointments and also presents you
with  so you have your
telephony status your availability which is
also accessible via the
telephony application and in gmail not
only is the application present
but will also be able to analyze all the
numbers you receive in your
e-mails which allows you  to simply
click on the phone number of a
contact in his signature to be able
to communicate with this
person
obviously when you mention from an
administration point of view it is the
base we use the google base
so you do not have  not to recreate the
users it's a
centralized provisioning so either I'm
just an example I invite you
we have a stand
outside to come and see our demonstration
it will give you the visual a little
stronger to see how our
client is  is integrated into all
levels of the google suite is to have
a small user experience and on
this I will invite serge who is a
customer who will testify to his
experience why and how he
chose ring central
thank you it's hello to all so I
am a google user and a Jesuit in
particular for a long time
haiti mix is a company one of the scene
which is an expert in digit
l systems connect a Frenc
company present in  france in canada
in germany in benelux in several
places in europe 600 employees
very often mobile whose
average age is 31 years old we integrated
google solutions at the start precisely because,
as anna said very well,
we wanted to be very  collaborative on
projects where we work not only
with teams that are remote but
also with clients that we have integrated into
our digital ecosystem to be able to
be very efficient I found it
so effective so I have a
functional vision of the  things that i have
decided to be google partner is
distributed among others all
google solutions for work
towards my client  ts who are in
the world of innovation or the
contribution of this type of tool is
really very substantial both from the
point of view of functions and costs
recently so in the google ecosystem
I became aware of the risk offer
central and that was concomitant with
the desire for growth of the company
which happened to have to move to
much larger premises where
the image was important where we
wanted to have very mobile employees
who did not necessarily have a
place of  styles
and constantly to receive them but to
move to receive external speakers
from clients since we have a
coworking space which is intended for
our clients with whom we
brainstorm and have produced and I
also had constraints so two places
I don't  wanted I didn't see why
I still had to have telephone handsets
I didn't see why I
still had to contribute financially to
fatten the ops  erators and I
also wanted on board to enroll our
remote collaborators by making
sure that they have
a telephone number on their business card when
they were with one client or
another for a certain period of time, so
this solution was integrated into the  favor
of a very rapid move
and what is also interesting about this
session is that it is very scalable
we are in a fairly significant growth rate
we also have a lot of incoming and outgoing
employees so it is  very easy to
manage with a drilles centrale type tool
good portability of numbers
etc
for me it went without saying but on
digging it turned out that in the
solutions we examined it was not
obvious eric centrale to offer this
possibility but I don't want to
dwell on it so much
let's say that from a functional point of view
it's a little as if I don't know
that there are tools like spotify
in his personal rhythm there are people
who say this type of tool yes
can bring it there maybe here I
am so you probably have
you probably no longer have a
cd dvd player etc
me so I wanted to be in this
dynamic where we don't  there is nothing left and where we have
the possibility of historicizing the
telephone conversations because
we also have sales representatives we have a
very important recruitment activity which at
one time or another the follow-up is no
longer enough we must have telephone contact
with the people they  don't
necessarily have the company's solutions
is the only way to reach them these the
telephone
we have to be able to historicize very quickly
keep in touch at
reasonable costs since we can
call candidates who are
all over the world that's
it  today we have 130 workstations
installed and the next step is to
deploy this to our 600 employees
always with the same efficiency so
in the uses anyway good we
are specialized in all the systems  th
industrial digital and therefore often
critical systems
for example we are working on a
train switching system or the
braking systems of trains or cars good
I would not swear that I would put
central risk tomorrow morning to
replace a braking system of
train in terms of reliability there are
still small problems especially
when we work with our
collaborators in secure vpn it
sometimes presents some problems but
there too we wanted
the solution to be so convincing to be an
integrator of the solutions a central
and we are working to improve these
points  there I thank you
[Applause]